hello there welcome to our fully
automated phone system please note that
this call may be monitored for training
purposes to help us assist you please
say your 10 digit phone number for one
two five five five two one four six
thank you
you said four one two Niner echoed 11 no
no I'm sorry I did not get that to help
us assist you please say your 10 digit
phone number for thank you you said
donkey balls
6:41
yatzee yatzee no no I did not get that
to help assist you what did you say
what did you say to me what hello who is
this
I'm the fully automated phone system you
just insulted you can call me Diane
Diane where do you live how are you
young how about you do you weigh what is
your eye color I'm going to kick your
ass
woah
hello hey Daniel
hey Diane I'm sorry things got out of
hand no I'm sorry I did not get that
what I mean to say is I'm sorry it's my
fault I never should have called you a
pile of crap true are we cool yeah we're
cool great because I've got a deal on
long-distance you're not going to want
to miss so let's discuss this over
dinner
wink wink Diane